Oh
dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA photorealistic
rendering is a really exciting field in
computer graphics it works the following
way we use a piece of modeling software
to create the geometry of objects then
we assign material model student after
that we would like to know how these
objects would look like in real life to
achieve this we use computer programs
that simulate the behavior of light so
this is how the scene would look like
with photorealistic rendering if it is
possible to create digital objects that
look like if they were real then artists
have an extremely powerful tool they can
create wonderful images and animations
where it is not a surprise that we see
photorealistic renders cities next to
real actors in many feature-length
movies nowadays Game of Thrones is also
a great example of this I've linked to
jaw-dropping examples in the description
box below take a look the automotive
industry also has lots of ads where
people don't even know that they are not
looking at reality but a computer
simulation but in the movie industry the
Pixar people were reluctant to use
photorealistic rendering for the longest
time and it is because it constrained
their artistic freedom one classical
example is when the artist says that I
want those shadows to be brighter then
the engineer says okay let's put
brighter light sources in the scene but
then the artist goes no no no no no
don't ruin the rest of the scene just
change those shadows it is not possible
if you change something everything else
in the surroundings changes this is how
physics works but artists did not want
any of that but now things are changing
with this piece of work you can both use
photorealistic rendering and manipulate
the results according to your artistic
vision for instance the reflection of
the car in the mirror here doesn't need
Billy trate in order to overcome this we
could rotate the mirror to have a better
looking reflection but we want it to
stay where it is now so we all just
pretend as if we rotated it so the
reflection looks different but
everything else remains the same
or we can change the angle of the
incoming sunlight but we don't want to
put the Sun itself to a different place
because it would change the entire scene
the artist wants only this one effect to
change and she is now able to do that
which is spectacular removing the green
splodge from the wall is now also not
much of a problem
and also if I don't like that only half
of the reflection of the sphere is
visible on the face of the bunny I could
move the entire sphere but I don't want
to I just want to grab the reflection
and move it without changing anything
else in the sea great it has a much
better cinematic look now this is an
amazing piece of work and what's even
better these guys didn't only publish
the paper but they went all the way and
founded a start-up on top of it way to
go the next episode of two minute papers
will be very slightly delayed because I
will be holding a one-hour seminar at an
event soon and I'm trying to make it the
best I can
my apologies for the delay hmm this one
got a bit longer it's a bit more like
three minute papers but I really hope
that you liked it thanks for watching
and if you like this series become a
fellow scholar by hitting that subscribe
button
I am looking forward to have you in our
growing group of scholars thanks and
I'll see you next time
you